The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at osu.mit.edu.
ROBERT FIELD: You know that
there is exam tomorrow night.
It's very heavily
on the particle
in a box, the
harmonic oscillator,
and the time-independent
Schrodinger equation.
It's really quite an
amazing amount of stuff.
OK.
So last time, we talked
about some time-independent
Hamiltonian examples.
And two that I like are the
half harmonic oscillator
and the vertical excitation--
the Franck-Condon excitation.
Now, when you're doing
time-dependent Hamiltonians--
or when you're doing
time-dependent problems
for a time-independent
Hamiltonian--
You always start with the
form of the function at t
equals zero and
automatically extend
it using the fact that
you have a complete set
of eigenfunctions of the
time-independent Hamiltonian
to the time-dependent
wave function.
And with the time-dependent
wave function,
you're able to calculate
almost anything you want.
And I did several
examples of things
that you could calculate.
One is the probability
density as a function of time.
So the other is the
survival probability.
And the survival probability
is a really neat thing,
because it says, we've got some
object which is particle-like.
And the time evolution
makes the wave function
move away from its birthplace.
And that's an easy
thing to understand,
but what's surprising is that
we think about a wave packet as
localized in
position, but it also
has encoded in it
momentum information.
And so when the wave
packet moves away
from its starting point--
if it starts at rest--
The initial fast
changes are in momentum.
And the momentum-- the
change of the momentum--
is sampling the gradient
of the potential.
And that's something you
usually want to know.
The gradient of the
potential at a turning
point-- at an energy you know.
And that is a
measurable quantity.
And it's really a
beautiful example
of how you can find easily
observable, or easily
calculable, quantum
mechanical things that
reflect classical mechanics.
OK.
I talked about grand rephasings
for problems like the harmonic
oscillator, and the rigid rotor,
and the particle in a box--
You have this fantastic property
that all of the energy level
differences are integer
multiples of a common factor.
And that guarantees
that you will
have periodic
rephasings at times
related to that common factor.
And so that enables
you to observe
the evolution of something
for a very long time
and to see whether
the rephasings are
perfect or not quite perfect.
And the imperfections
are telling you something
beyond the simple model--
They're telling you
about anharmonicity
or some other thing that makes
the energy levels not quite
integer multiples
of a common factor.
Now, one of the nicest things is
the illustration of tunneling.
And we don't observe tunneling.
Tunneling is a quantum
mechanical thing.
And it's encoded in what's most
easily observed-- the energy
level pattern.
It's encoded as a
level staggering.
Now, we talked about
this problem, where we
have a barrier in the middle.
And with a barrier
in the middle,
half of the energy levels
are almost unaffected,
and the other half
are affected a lot.
Now, here is a problem
that you can understand--
In the same way, there's
no tunneling here,
but there is some
extra stuff here.
And the level diagram can
tell you the difference
between these two things.
Does anybody want to
tell me what's different?
What is the qualitative
signature of this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The spacings
move up a little bit.
The odd spacings are
erased in energy,
and the even spacings are
just about unaffected.
ROBERT FIELD: Even symmetry
levels are shifted up.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Sorry.
ROBERT FIELD: And so now you're
ready to answer this one.
If the even symmetry
levels are shifted up,
because they feel the
barrier, what about the even
symmetry levels here?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: They would
be shifted down.
ROBERT FIELD: Right.
And so you get a level
staggering where, in this case,
the lowest level is close
to the next higher one.
And in this one, the lowest
level is shifted way down,
and the next one is not shifted.
And then we get the
doubling or the parent.
So that's a kind of
intuition that you get just
by looking at these problems.
Now, one thing that
is really beautiful
is, when you have a
barrier like this,
since this part of
the potential problem
is something that
is exactly solved,
you propagate the wave
function in from the sides
and they have the same phase.
So there is no accumulation
of phase under the barrier.
And that means the
levels that are trying
to propagate under this
barrier are shifted up,
because they have to accumulate
enough phase to satisfy
the boundary conditions
at the turning points.
Here, you're going to
accumulate more phase
in this special region.
Phase is really important.
OK.
So today we're going to talk--
And this this lecture is
basically not on the exam,
although it does connect
with topics on the exam
and makes it possible to
understand them better.
So instead of learning
about the postulates
in a great abstract way at the
beginning, before you know what
they're for, now
we're going to review
what we understand about them.
And so one thing is,
there is a wave function.
And now we're considering
not just one dimension,
but any number of dimensions.
And this is the
state function that
tells you everything
you're allowed
to know about the system.
And if you have this, you
can calculate everything.
If you know how
observables relate to this,
well, you're fine.
You can then use that to
describe the Hamiltonian.
Hermetian operators
are the only kind
of operators you can have
in quantum mechanics.
And they have the
wonderful property
that their eigenvalues--
all of them-- are real.
Because they correspond to
something that's observable.
And when you observe
something, it's a real number.
It's not a complex number.
It's not an imaginary number.
So what is Hermetian?
And why does that ensure that
you always get a real number?
OK.
You all know, in
quantum mechanics,
that if you do an experiment,
and the experiment can
be represented by
some operator, you
get an eigenvalue
of that operator--
nothing else-- one
experiment, one eigenvalue.
100 experiments-- You might
get several eigenvalues.
And the relative probabilities
of the different eigenvalues--
I tell you something
about, what is this?
What was the
initial preparation?
So I've already said
something about this.
The expectation value
of the wave function
for a particular operator is
related to probabilities times
eigenvalues.
OK.
The fifth postulate is the
time-dependent Schrodinger
equation.
And I don't need to talk
much about that, because it's
all the way around us.
And then I'm going to talk about
some neat stuff where we start
using words that are very
instructive-- so completeness,
orthogonality, commutators--
simultaneous eigenfunctions.
And this is really important.
Suppose we have an
easy operator, which
commutes with the Hamiltonian.
And it's easy for us to find the
eigenvalues of that operator--
eigenfunctions of that operator.
Those eigenfunctions are
automatically eigenfunctions.
It's a hard operator.
So we like them.
And so we are
interested in, can we
have simultaneous eigenfunctions
of several operators?
And the answer is yes, if
the operators can move.
We use the term
basis set to describe
the complete set
of eigenfunctions
of some operator.
And we use the words
mixing coefficients
and mixing fraction.
So here we have a
wave function that
is expressed as a linear
combination of basis functions.
And the coefficient
in front of each one
is the mixing coefficient.
Now, if we're talking
about probabilities,
we care about mixing
fractions, which
are basically the mixing
coefficient squared--
or [INAUDIBLE] square modulus.
So these are words that are
part of the language of someone
who uses quantum mechanics
to understand stuff.
OK.
So I'm going to try to develop
this in some useful tricks.
So we have a state function.
So we have a state
function, which
is a function of
coordinates and time.
And this thing is
telling you, what
is the probability of finding
this system at that coordinate
at the specified time?
And the volume element
is dx, dy, and dz.
Now, often, we use
an abbreviation--
d tau-- for the volume
element, because we're
going to be dealing
with problems
that are not just single
particle, but many particles.
And so we use this
notation to say,
for the differential associated
with every coordinate
associated with the
problem, and we're
going to integrate over
those sorts of things--
or at least over some of them.
So this is telling you about
a probability within a volume
element at a particular
point in space and time.
Now, one of the
things that we're told
is, if the wave functions
are well behaved.
And that says something
about the wave functions
and the derivatives
of the wave functions.
So what's well-behaved?
Well, the wave function
is normalize-able.
Now, there are two kinds of
normalization-- normalization
to one, implying that the system
is somewhere within a specified
range of coordinates
where there's
one particle in the system.
Whatever.
And there's normalization
to number density.
When you have a free
particle, the free particle
is not confined.
And so you can't
say, I'm normalizing.
So there's one
particle somewhere,
because that means there
is no particle anywhere.
And so we can extend the
concept of normalization to say,
there's one particle
in a particular length
of the system.
And that was a problem
that got removed
from the draft of the exam.
But one thing that happens is,
if I write a beautiful problem,
and it gets bumped from an exam,
it might appear in the final.
OK.
So normalize-able is part
of well-behaved continuous
and single value--
we'll talk about all of these--
and square integrable
OK.
Continuous-- The
wave function has
to be continuous everywhere.
The first derivative
of the wave function,
with respect to coordinate--
we already know from
the particle in a box
that that is not continuous
at an infinite wall.
So an infinite wall--
not just a vertical wall, but
one that goes to infinity--
guarantees that this
guy is not continuous.
But that's a pretty
dramatic thing.
The second derivative
is not continuous
when you have a vertical
step, which is not infinite.
Now, when you have problems
where you divide space up
into regions,
you're often trying
to establish boundary conditions
between the different regions
or at the borders.
And the boundary
conditions are usually
expressed in terms of
continuity of the wave function
and continuity of
the first derivative.
And we don't need this often.
But you're entitled-- if
the problem is sufficiently
well-behaved--
All of these guys
are continuous,
and you can use them all.
OK.
So normalize-able--
Well, normalize-able
means it's square integrable,
and you don't get infinity
unless we use this other
definition of normalize-able.
So one of the things
that has to happen
is, at the coordinate
plus and minus infinity,
the wave function
has to go to zero.
Now, the wave function can be
infinite at a very small region
of space.
So there are singularities
that can be dealt with.
But normally, you say,
the wave function is never
going to be infinite,
and it's never
going to be anything
but 0 at infinity,
or you're in real trouble.
Now, there is a
wonderful example
of a kind of a problem
called the delta function.
A delta function is
basically an infinite spike--
infinitely thin,
infinitely tall.
And what it does
is, it causes this
to be discontinuous
by an amount related
to the value of the
derivative at the--
by an amount determined
by the value of the wave
function at the delta function.
And delta functions are
computationally wonderful,
because they enable you to
treat certain kinds of problems
in a trivial way.
Like, if you have a barrier--
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does it relate at all
to the integral of the spike?
ROBERT FIELD: Yes.
So we have an integral
of the delta function
at x i times the wave
function at x, dx.
And that gives you the
wave function at x i.
OK.
I haven't really talked
much about delta functions.
But because it
acts like a barrier
and is a trivial
barrier, it enables
you to solve barrier problems
or at least understand them
in a very quick and easy way.
And vertical steps
are also not physical,
but we like vertical
steps because it's
easy to apply
boundary conditions.
And so these are all just
computationally tricky things
that are wonderful.
And we don't worry
about, is there
a real system that acts
like a delta function
or a vertical step?
No.
There isn't.
But everything you get
easily, mathematically,
from these simple
things is great.
OK.
Did I satisfy you on the--
AUDIENCE: Sure.
I'll read into it.
ROBERT FIELD: OK.
And there's also
a notation where
you have x, xi, or x minus
x i, and they're basically
all the same sort of thing.
If you have this--
the argument-- when
the argument is 0,
you get the infinite spike.
And there's just lots of things.
OK.
So for every classical
mechanical observable,
there is a quantum mechanical
operator, which is Hermetian.
And the main point of
Hermetian, as I said,
is that its
eigenvalues are real.
And so what is the
thing that assures
that we get real eigenvalues?
Well, here is the definition
in a peculiar form.
So we have an integral from
minus infinity to infinity
of some function--
complex conjugate--
a times some other function dx.
So this could be a wave function
and a different wave function.
And the definition of Hermetian
is this abstract definition.
We have, say, interval
from minus infinity
to infinity g a--
Let's put a hat on it.
Star, f-star, dx.
Well, this is kind of fancy.
So we have an operator.
We can take the complex
conjugate of the operator.
We have functions.
We can take the complex
conjugates of the function.
But here, what we're
seeing is, the operator
is operating on the g
function-- the function
that started out on the right.
And here, what we have is
this operator operating
on the f function, which
was initially on the left.
And so this is prescription
for operating on the left.
And it's also an
invitation to use
a really convenient
and compact notation.
And that is this--
Put two subscripts on a.
A subscript says the first
guy is the function over here,
which is complex conjugated.
And the second one
is the function
over here, which is
not complex conjugated.
And so this equation reduces
to a g f star, where, now, this
is a wonderful shorthand.
And this is another
way of saying that A
has to be equal to A dagger.
Where now we're talking
about operators,
and matrix representations
of operators.
Because here we have a
number with two indices,
and that's how we represent
elements of a matrix.
And we're soon going to be
playing with linear algebra,
and talking about matrices.
And so this is just saying,
well, we can take one matrix,
and it's equal to
the complex conjugate
of every term in the matrix.
And the order switched.
So this is a warning
that we're going
to be using a notation, which
is way simpler than taking
these integrals.
And so once you recognize
what this symbol means,
you're never going
to want to go back.
OK.
Why real?
So let's look at a
specific example,
where instead of having two
different functions, let's just
look at one.
So we have this
integral f star A f d x.
So that's a f f.
And the definition says,
well, we're going to get the--
So it says, replace the
original thing by moving this--
anyway, yes.
And this is a f f star.
If you know how this
notation translates into--
now you can see, oh,
well, what is this?
It's just taking the
complex conjugate.
And these two guys are equal.
And so a number is real if it's
equal to its complex conjugate.
And this is just a special case.
It's-- the Hermitian property is
a little bit more powerful than
that, but the important thing is
that it guarantees that if you
calculate the expectation value
of an observable quantity,
you're going to
get a real number,
if the operator is Hermitian.
And it has to be Hermitian,
if it's observable.
Now, it's often
useful if you have
a classical mechanical
operator, and you translate it
into a quantum
mechanical operator
by doing the usual replacement
of x with x, and p with i
h bar, the derivative
with respect to x.
If you do all that sort of
stuff, you might be unlucky
and you might get a
non-Hermitian operator.
And so you can generate
a Hermitian operator
if you write--
that's guaranteed
to be Hermitian.
So you take classic mechanics,
you generate something
following some simple rules,
and you have bad luck,
it doesn't come out
to be Hermitian.
This is the way we
make it Hermitian.
So if this is not Hermitian,
and this is not Hermitian,
but that we're defining
something that is Hermitian,
so let's just put a
little twiddle over A,
that's Hermitian.
OK then we're now talking
about the third postulate,
and each measurement of a
gives an eigenvalue of a.
We've talked about this enough.
But your first encounter of this
was the Two-Slit experiment.
In the Two-Slit experiment,
this experiment is an operator.
And you have some initial
photons entering this operator
, and you get dots,
on the screen,
those are eigenvalues
of this operator.
Now it may be that the operator
has continuous eigenvalues,
but they don't have
uniform probabilities.
And so what you observe is a
whole distribution of dots that
doesn't look like
anything special,
and it's not reproducible from
one experiment to the other,
but you have this periodic
structure that's appearing,
which is related to the
properties of the operator.
And so there is not
uniform probabilities
of each eigenvalues,
and so you get that.
OK, these are simple,
but really beautiful.
OK, if we have a normalized
state then we can say, OK,
and we never use this notation.
But whenever you
see this symbol,
it means the expectation value
of an operator for some wave
functions, so we could
actually symbolically put
that wave function down here,
or some symbols saying, OK,
which one?
And that this is equal to
psi star A psi d tau, or dx.
And if the wave
function is normalized,
we don't need to divide by
a normalization integral.
If it's not normalized, like
if it's a free particle,
we divide by some kind of
free particle integral.
So now the next topic,
which is related to this,
is completeness
and orthogonality.
So we have a
particular operator.
There exists some complete
set of eigenfunctions
of that operator.
Usually that complete
set is infinite,
but they're related to
each other in a simple way.
You have some
class of functions,
and you change an integer
to get a new function.
And orthogonality is, well, if
you have all the eigenfunctions
of an operator, if they belong
to different eigenvalues,
they're guaranteed
to be orthogonal.
Which is convenient, because
that means you get lots of 0s
from integrals, and we
like that, because we
don't have to worry about them.
And you want to be able to
recognize the zero integrals,
so that you can move very
quickly through a problem.
Completeness means, take
any function defined
on the space of the operator
you're interested in.
You might have an
operator that's
only operating on a particular
coordinate of a many electron
atom or molecule.
There's lots of ways of saying,
it's not over all space,
but for each operator you
know what space the operator
in question is dealing with.
And then it's always
possible to write.
So this is some
general function,
defined in the space
of the operator,
and this is the equation
that says, well, completeness
tells us that we can
take the sum over all
of the eigenfunctions
with mixing coefficients.
c j.
And this set of all
of the eigenfunctions
is called the basis set.
It's a complete basis set.
So it's always true,
you can do this.
So you know from other
problems, that if you
have a finite region of space,
you can represent anything
within that finite region via
sum over Fourier components.
That's a discrete sum.
If you have an
infinite space, you
have to do a Fourier
integral, but it's basically
the same thing.
You're expressing a
function, anything you want,
in terms of simple,
manipulable objects.
So sometimes the these things
are Fourier components,
and sometimes they're just
simple wave functions.
OK, now suppose you have
two operators, a and b.
If they operate
over the same space,
the question is, can we
take eigenfunctions of one
and be sure that they're
eigenfunctions of the other?
OK, but let's deal
with something simpler.
So suppose we have psi i and
psi j, both belong to a sub i.
So they both have
the same eigenvalue.
Well, in that case, we cannot
be sure that these two functions
are orthogonal.
So there is a handy
dandy procedure
called Schmidt
Orthogonalization that
says, take any two
functions, and let's
construct an orthogonal pair.
This is amazingly
useful when you're
trying to understand
a problem using
a complete
orthonormal basis set.
We know, I'm not
going to prove it,
because I don't know where
it is in my notes, what
the sequence is, I'm
just going to forget it--
I think I'm going to do it.
If you have functions belonging
to different eigenvalues,
they are automatically
orthogonal.
That's also really valuable,
because you have to check.
So you have harmonic
oscillator functions,
and they're all
orthogonal to each other.
You have, perhaps, one
harmonic oscillator,
and a different
and the functions for these two
different harmonic oscillators
don't know about each other.
They're not guaranteed
to be orthogonal.
But any two eigenvalues of
this guy are orthogonal,
and any of those are orthogonal.
But not here.
OK, so let's just
say we have now two
eigenfunctions of
an operator that
belong to the same eigenvalues.
And that happens.
There are often very many,
very high degeneracies.
But we want to make
sure that we've got two.
So let's say, here is a
number, the overlap integral
between psi 1 and psi 2 dx.
This is a calculable number.
So you have two
original functions,
which are not guaranteed
to be orthogonal,
because they belong to
the same eigenvalue,
and you can calculate
this number.
And then we can say, let us
now construct something up psi
2, which is guaranteed to be a
psi 2 prime which is guaranteed
to be orthogonal to psi 1.
How do we do that?
Well, we define psi 2
to be a normalization
factor, times psi
2 the original,
plus some constant times psi 1.
And then we say, let us
calculate the overlap integral
between psi 1 and psi 2 prime.
OK, so we do that.
And so we have the integral, and
we have psi 1 star times psi 2
plus a psi 1 dx.
Psi 1 on psi 1 is 1.
So we get an a.
And psi 1 star
times psi 2 gives s.
So this integral,
which is supposed
to be 0, because
we want psi 1 to be
orthogonal to psi 2 prime, is
going to be n times s plus a.
Well, how do we satisfy this?
We just make a to be minus s.
Guaranteed.
Now this is one of
the tricks that I use
the most when I do derivations.
I want orthogonal functions,
and this little Schmidt
Orthogonalization enables
me to take my simple idea
and propagate it into
a complicated problem.
It's very valuable.
You'll probably never
use it, but I love it.
So if a is equal to minus
s, you've got orthogonality.
And the general formula
is psi 2 prime is equal
to 1 minus x squared,
the square root of that,
times psi 2 minus s psi 1.
So this is a normalized function
which is orthogonal to psi 1.
And it doesn't take much work.
You calculate one
interval, and it's done.
Now later in the
course, we're going
to talk we're going to talk
about a secular determinant
that you use to solve
for all the eigenvalues
and eigenfunctions of
a complicated problem.
And often, when you do that,
you use convenient functions
which are not guaranteed
to be orthogonal.
And there is a procedure you
apply to this secular matrix,
which orthogonalizes it first.
Then you diagonalize
a simple thing,
and then you undiagonalize,
if you need to.
Anyway, this is terribly
valuable, especially
when you're doing quantum
chemistry, which you're
going to see towards the end.
OK.
Often, we would like to express
a particular eigenfunction
expectation value as
a sum over P i a i.
So this is a probability.
And so how do we do that?
Certainly, the average
of this operator over psi
can be written as the
eigenvalues of a times
the probability
of each operator.
And what are they?
Well, you can show that
this is equal to c i--
I better be careful here.
Well, let's just do it.
Well, I'll just write it.
Where this is the
mixing coefficient
of the eigenfunction of a
in the original function.
So we get probabilities
mixing fractions,
and we have mixing coefficients.
And this is the
language we're going
to use to describe many things.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT FIELD: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: The
probability doesn't
have an a i, the average does.
You just remove the a i.
ROBERT FIELD: So
the probability--
AUDIENCE: The probability--
ROBERT FIELD: Oh, yes.
You see, when I start
lecturing from what's
in my addled brain--
OK, thank you.
OK.
Now let's do some
really neat things.
So we have a commutator
of two operators.
If that commutator is 0,
then all non-degenerate
eigenfunctions of A are
eigenfunctions of B.
If this is not equal to 0,
then we can say something about
the variances of A and B. So
these quantities are greater
than or equal to minus
1/4 times the integral--
I better write this
on the board below.
And this is greater
than 0, and real.
This is the
uncertainty principle.
So it's possible to prove
this, and it's really strange,
because we have a
square of a number here.
We think the square of a
number is going to be real,
but not if it's imaginary.
Most non-zero commutators
are imaginary.
And so this thing is
negative, and it's canceled.
So the joint uncertainty is
related to the expectation
value of a commutator.
And this is all traced back
to x P x is equal to ih bar.
And this commutator
is imaginary.
And everything that
appears in here,
it comes from the
non-commutation
of coordinate and momentum.
And this is why this
commutator is often
regarded as the foundation
of quantum mechanics.
Because all of the
strangeness comes from it.
So yes, this is surprising.
It's saying that, when we
have a non-zero commutator,
this is what determines the
joint uncertainty of two
properties.
This commutator is
always imaginary,
that is a big, big surprise.
And as a result the joint
uncertainty is greater than 0,
If the two operators
don't commute,
it's because x and
P don't commute.
It's really scary.
OK, what time is it?
We've got five minutes left,
and I can do one more thing.
Well, I guess I'm going
to be just talking about--
So the uncertainty principle.
If we know operator A and B, we
can calculate their commutator.
This is a property
of the operators.
It doesn't have to
do with constructing
some clever experiment,
where you tried to measure
two things simultaneously.
It says, all of the problems
with simultaneous observations
of two operators, two things,
comes from the structure
of the operators.
Comes from their
commutation rule.
Which traces all the way back to
the commutator between x and P.
So at the beginning, I said I
don't like these experiments,
where we try to confine the
coordinate of the photon
or the electron, and it
results in uncertainty
in the measurement of
the conjugate property,
the momentum, or
something like that.
These experiments depend on your
cleverness, but this doesn't.
This Is fundamental.
So I like that a lot better.
OK, the last thing I
want to talk about,
which I have just barely
enough time to do,
is suppose we have
a wave function.
Let's call it psi 2 in quotes
of x for the particle in a box.
Particle in a infinite box.
This is a wave function, which
is not the eigenfunction,
but it is constructed to
look like the eigenfunction.
Mainly because it has the
right number of nodes.
And so suppose we
call this thing
some normalization factor x x
minus a and x minus a over 2.
This guarantees you have
a node at x equals 0.
a node at x equals a.
This guarantees you have a
node at x equals a over 2.
So this is that the
generic property
of the second eigenfunction
for the particle in a box.
And this is a very clever
guess, and often you
want to make a guess.
And so, how well
you do with a guess?
And so this function,
this part of it
looks sort of like this between
x and a, and this part of it
looks like this.
And we multiply
these two together
and we get something
that looks like this.
Which is, at least
a sketch, looks
like the n equals
2 eigenfunction
with a particle in a box.
So let's just go through
and see how well we can do.
So first of all, we
have to determine n.
So we do the
normalization integral.
Psi 2 star psi 2 dx.
That has to be 1.
So what we do, now this
is kind of a cheat,
because we do this because we
don't know an eigenfunction.
But we do know these
eigenfunctions,
so we can expand
these functions,
in terms of the particle
in a box eigenfunctions.
So we use these things,
which you know very well.
Now we have a sine
function here.
That's because I've
chosen the box that
doesn't have 0 left edge, it's
symmetric about x equals 0.
And that would be appropriate
for this kind of function.
So anyway, when we do this, we
find the mixing coefficients.
And I know I just
said something wrong
and that's, we don't
have time to correct it.
Because I said it the wave
function is 0 at x equals 0,
and at x equals a.
And I'm now saying,
all of a sudden
I'm using symmetric box--
this does not matter,
because the calculation
is done correctly.
And what we end up
getting, is that the mixing
coefficients for these functions
of the general form, 800--
I'm sorry, 840--
this is algebra!--
Square root a to the
minus 7/2 2 over n--
2 over a.
I think that's a.
Well, I'm not sure
whether that's a or n,
but let's just say it's
2 over n square root--
oh, it's going to be 2 over a.
And times the
integral-- anyway, so we
get c 2n is equal to 1680 square
root over 6 over 2n pi cubed.
And that becomes equal to
0.9914n to the minus 3.
So this is a general formula
which you can derive.
I don't recommend
it, and I don't
think it's really important.
The important thing is
what I'm about to say.
And I have no time.
This is almost 1.
So when we calculate the
energy using these functions,
we get that the energy
of this 2n function
is equal to 4E1 times
0.983 integral from n
equals 1 to infinity
times n to the minus 4.
OK, the first term
and this is 1.
And so we have something
that looks like 4 times E1.
Now the sum is larger than one,
and the product of these two
things is larger than 1.
And so what we get is that, E2n
is larger, but only slightly
larger, than the exact results.
So this is sort of a taste
of a variation calculation.
We can solve for the
form of a function
by doing a minimization of
the energy of that function.
And that function will look
like the true function,
but its energy will always be
larger than the true function.
But it's great, because
the bigger the calculation,
the better you do.
And that's how most of
the money, the computer
time in the world, is expended.
Doing large variational
calculations
to find eigenfunctions
of complicated problems.
OK, good luck on the exam.
I hope you find it fun,
and I meant it to be fun.